- So if you want,
in this triangular enclave,
what would you like a rap about?
- [Audience Member 1] Ireland.
- Ireland, are you yourself Irish?
- [Audience Member 1] No.
- No?
No, no, why'd you go, "No, ew, eww.
What? No."
- [Audience Member 1]
My boyfriend's Irish.
- Your boyfriend's Irish.
Exactly, and he's not here tonight.
Ew, ew.
(audience laughing)
What aspect of Ireland would
you like us to focus on?
- [Audience Member 1] Oh God, music!
- Music, Irish music?
- [Audience Member 1] Yeah.
- Fun, great that's a great suggestion.
Are there any Irish bands
that you particularly enjoy?
- [Audience Member 1] My
boyfriend's a musician.
- Your boyfriend's an Irish musician.
The imagination on display.
This is really cool.
(audience laughs)
You could have picked anything.
You're just like,
"the guy that I kind of
like, but also (indistinct)"
Irish musicians, lovely,
your boyfriend is one.
Let's come to the back of the room,
I want to give you guys an opportunity.
- [Audience Member 2] Colonization.
- What was that?
- Colonization.
(audience laughs)
I can't see you, since
it's quite dim over there,
and I can't hear from your accent,
are you from a country that was colonized?
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member 2] By you, yeah.
- By me?
(audience laughs)
You're welcome, slash I'm sorry.
May I inquire as to the country?
- [Audience Member 2] The U.S.
- The U.S.
(audience laughs)
I mean,
(audience continues laughing)
okay cool, yeah.
I mean, I'm sorry, slash
you're welcome still holds.
Okay, colonization of
the U.S. by the British.
Irish musicians.
Let's come to the middle of the room.
From this side to this side.
What you want a rap about?
- [Audience Member 3]
Gothic Catholic churches.
- Gothic Catholic churches.
Thank you very much, cool.
Just so you know, gothic is
the style of architecture.
Not Catholic churches that wear all black
and you know, self harm.
And are you thinking of
gothic or neo-gothic?
- [Audience Member 3] Oh.
(audience groans)
- No, what you sit at
home and, "Oh, Wikipedia."
It's just a, we'll figure it out.
Okay, colonization of the state,
Irish musicians, gothic Catholic churches.
Let's come to the middle
section of the room,
and don't worry people over
here will come to you last up.
Middle of the room, what do you want?
- [Audience Members] matzo ball soup,
the Queen, a slutty taxidermist,
(indistinct) missionary.
- There were so, so many.
We had matzo ball soup, the Queen,
you said a slutty taxidermist.
(audience laughs)
We found the crowd favorite.
A slutty taxidermist.
Okay, and then this section of the room,
you have the final suggestion.
Usually I'd say make it the best,
but slutty taxidermist
is real fucking good.
(audience laughs)
- [Audience Member 4] Double decker bus!
- Double decker bus.
Thank you for the
emphasis on that as well.
Double decker bus, yeah!
(audience laughs)
Whoa!
That is what all British
people think Americans are like
when they're in London.
Whoa! Buckingham Palace,
guard with a big hat!
So these are our topics.
Irish musician,
colonization of the states,
gothic Catholic churches,
slutty taxidermy.
If I remember, I'll throw in
the Queen and matzo ball soup
and a double decker bus, yeah!
(audience laughs)
So my lovely band it's been,
I've been away since April.
Right so, I'm excited to get back together
with you guys again.
Yeah, we broke up, we went
on hiatus and now we're back.
So let's,
my gosh are you gonna break
the speakers with that?
(audience laughs)
Oh no, that's not a criticism.
Red's like, "Oh, I'm really sorry Chris,
I'll change it for a less 808-y sound."
So beautiful.
Isn't it nice?
Why are you doing this with your face?
You seem apprehensive.
You're now fanning yourself.
Okay, cool.
We'll start it off.
You seem perturbed,
'bout how this might end.
Put him on blast, yeah
rap about my friend.
He's a boy but not here,
on my right I came out,
comedy cellar my gal tonight.
Where's he from?
His skin's ever so pasty white.
He eat potatoes, never sees the daylight.
Well if I like him, maybe just a little.
He plays, I presume the Irish
fiddle or some type of flute.
Oh fiddle dee-dee, when I get quite drunk,
he might fiddle with me
consensually, obviously.
My hand inspired about the
boyfriend from Ireland.
Is he Northern Irish or
there from the Republic?
Can he read sheet music and instruct it
like a conductor in the Irish orchestra?
It's just leprechauns with ginger hair
and they lept from there
over here to this country.
Moving back in the day, in the 1600s.
They're on the Mayflower Pilgrim Fathers.
They're from England, but they're like,
"We'd rather go to nicer
climates with more sun.
Let's set sail across the
sea and find a new one.
Oh America, yeah, we don't hate this.
Oh, hello! There's the
Indians, the native.
Give them the blankets, take it lots.
Now we own this 'cuz
you're dead of small pox."
I'm not encouraging it.
Obviously it was sad.
Colonization, it really turned out bad.
But let me talk about
something that's so much
much more pretty, see?
Over there in the middle century of Italy.
The Catholic church, they're
like, we won't stop it.
Construct all the houses of
worship in the gothic style.
And if you let your brain kind of art
they used to have the type of gothic arch.
The difference is it's not curved.
It's got a little point
that's hard to construct.
And that's my point.
Are you an architecture
student, far more prudent?
Nope, the Catholic church,
it's led by the Pope.
Who did they have?
Benedict and Paul.
What's his favorite soup?
Matzo ball.
(audience cheers)
He was eating it up, he's so keen.
Leader of the church,
would never meet the queen.
She runs the C of E,
the Church of England.
If they ever met, they would
get into fisticuffs like,
"Yo Popey, you better put them up.
I've got a thump with the
heft of a double decker bus.
Coming in, I'll aim
straight for your head.
Then I deck you twice,
double leave your face red with the blood
that's bubbling from your nose.
You saw these, a right hook coming
and then come the corgis,
they're attacking,
biting with their teeth."
The last thing you won't believe.
What I see, walk into a shop.
The action, it concerned me.
I see a guy there with this taxidermy.
He's got a dead beaver.
Yeah, he starts ruffling the hairs.
Then he says, "I'm giving it a stuffing."
What do you mean?
That's really yucky.
You're fucking the dead beaver.
Ew, yucky.
You'd be so slutty when
you see it with the fur,
slutty taxidermist, that's
a motherfucking perv.
(audience cheering)